beneath these shrouds or the faces of
men women and children their families
longed to see again long to know what
happened to them last week 31 husbands
grandmothers and daughters were buried
in an unmarked grave in the cemetery in
Iraq's Karbala province the Morgan
neighboring Babel province gave the
bodies to a local charity saying they
were unidentified and unclaimed there's
negligence on the part of the government
the government should have announced to
the public the existence of these bodies
DNA tests must be conducted to determine
their identities so that they can be
returned to their rightful relatives
human rights groups are accusing the
government of covering up possible
sectarian violence about 250 bodies have
been given to the same charity for
burial
since 2016 the governor of Bobble
province says they're from the area and
their causes of death range from what he
calls terrorism to murder suspicions
have been raised because witnesses say
the bodies are likely from a Sunni
dominated town called jerel Sahar it was
once controlled by ISIL during the
battle to defeat it Shia paramilitary
groups are accused of killing civilians
and forcibly displacing the population
the Iraqi High Commission for Human
Rights is calling on the government to
investigate reports of additional bodies
scattered beneath the soil in Bobble
province the government denies there is
anything suspicious going on how did you
have done there has been a lot of
negative media coverage in order to take
a sectarian turn these bodies were
stored at the morgue to be identified
after the investigation was over they
were buried because the bodies were not
claimed by their families but with so
many families in the area still living
in displacement camps that might explain
why no one came forward to identify the
250 bodies for all sunako dere knows her
son could be among them the family is
from jerk
El Sahar she hasn't seen her son since
2015 when she says a Shia armed group
accused him of being an ISIL member and
arrested him
her family was later driven out of their
home they're afraid if they return
they'll be killed he did nothing wrong
if he had I would testify against him
but as God is my witness he did nothing
wrong
who dared like so many Iraqis may never
know what happened to her loved one the
answers could be buried deep in the soil
of her country Natasha guy named al
jazeera Baghdad